[Musique]
oh
et
il était une fois une patate une
vulgaire patate comme nous en voyons
tous les jours mais dévoré d'ambition
le rêve de sa vie était de devenir
frites et c'est probablement ce qui
serait arrivé si
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
regarde comme tu es belle aux quelle
horreur je ressemble un bon savoir
puisque tu le prends comme ça je les
paie fort bien fréquenté il ya ici des
tas de gens intéressants qui a un qui
est cette personne qui ressemble à une
poêle à frire
bonjour madame la poêle à frire
vous êtes bien aimable je ne sais pas ce
qu est une poêle à frire
mais je ne suis pas n'importe qui je
m'appelle guitare et bien moi je
m'appelle pommes de terre mais vous
pouvez m'appeler patate
car je vous considère dès aujourd'hui
comme mon ami j'avais été choisi à cause
de ma beauté pour devenir
l'état valeur le petit garçon de la
maison ma pompe l'eau ne pleurait pas
mais vous êtes encore très bien
puis cela vous permet de parler mais
vous comment êtes vous venu ici au mois
j'étais l'ami d'un jeune garçon qui
m'aiment et tendrement me prenait dans
ses bras gratter des choses mais un jour
il est revenu avec une étrangère
vulgaire qu'il avait ensorcelé
je suis sûr qu'il ne l'aimait pas
d'ailleurs il n'avait pas confiance en
elle
il la tenait attaché avec une laisse moi
quand j'ai vu ça je compte et répartir
[Musique]
comme c'est beau je savais que nous
étions fait pour nous comprendre
d'ailleurs plus je vous regarde plus je
trouve que vous ressemblez à une poêle
ça c'est pas ordinaire une patate et une
guitare qui parle
s'il sait me prendre ma fortune est fait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est le directeur
qu'est ce que vous voulez monsieur le
directeur
j'ai une patate qui parle un bain vous
êtes sous mon avis et une guitare qui
répondent non je suis pas sous écoute
est allé parler toutes les deux mais
vous avez bien quelque chose à vous le
dire
dites moi mon avis vous payer ma tête
sortez maintenant à mais quand elles
sont toutes seules
alors c'est vrai faut parler toutes les
deux inutile de vous taire je vous
entends du dommage j'avais une belle
proposition à vous faire une proposition
artistique une proposition artistique
à la bonne heure eh bien oui vous allez
travailler
vous allez devenir fêter j'aimerais être
frites être free être mangé avec
d'autres talents ça se mange des frites
s'il en est ainsi j'aime mieux de venir
vous l'êtes le soir de la première fut
un énorme succès
parmi les spectateurs se trouvaient le
sultan de pétaouchnok qui s'appliquent
immédiatement de la pâte ap
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur le directeur du veut
épouser la pata mais voyons de bonnes
personnes
alors je vous la chair au vous faites
beaucoup de peurs et bien je vous
l'achète 1-1 voit-on de diama un seul do
do si vous voulez ils n'ont pas non plus
le lendemain le sultan repartait dans
son sultanat en emmenant la patate et
aussi la guitare car les deux amis ne
voulait pas se quitter
[Musique]
une semaine après les journaux
publiaient les photos du mariage du
sultan et de la patate